pues la situación es delicada desde el
pasado 14 de diciembre se superó el
récord que se había establecido en mayo
en cuanto a la hospitalización en la
ciudad al alcanzar cuatro mil 598
hospitalizaciones y desde entonces a la
fecha no ha bajado el promedio
actualmente pues estamos en cuatro mil
800 personas hospitalizadas de las
cuales una cuarta parte está en terapia
intensiva el gobierno capitalino ha
estado enviando mensajes de sms a la
población para alertar de la condición
crítica en la que se encuentran los
hospitales varios de ellos están a su
máxima capacidad y hoy se realizó un
simulacro de la vacuna elementos
militares fueron el aeropuerto a recoger
las dosis en este caso de la vacuna de
influenza pues la de kobe aún no llega
al país y la trasladaron a un batallón
al sur de la ciudad para también ensayar
el tiempo de inmunización que es de tres
minutos pero en efecto la situación en
la ciudad y en el estado de mexico es
complicada
mariah bogotanos como repercute en estos
anuncios en la sociedad precisamente en
la temporada navideña
así es ya en principio el sector de
comercio y turismo la confederación de
cámaras nacionales de comercio advirtió
que para muchos negocios será un golpe
final algunos comercios apenas estaban
recuperándose en sus ventas y con este
cierre pues tendrán de nueva cuenta que
cerrar y probablemente de manera
definitiva por lo que hacen un llamado
al gobierno a aplicar ahora sí apoyos
directos a las pequeñas a las micro a
las medianas empresas para que no
cierren sus puertas y se conserven los
empleos sin embargo pues la población
parece que aún no se toma en serio está
gravedad pues en las calles se ve mucho
tránsito de personas en los centros
comerciales un día antes de que cierren
por las medidas del gobierno están a una
buena capacidad hay mucha gente haciendo
compras de última hora y las encuestas
refieren pues que hay sensatez por otra
parte aunque parezca contradictorio 52
por ciento de acuerdo con una encuesta
del financiero no va a reunirse con su
familia
navidad de 82 no acudirá a fiestas con
amigos así las cosas en la ciudad de
méxico